OK.
So hi.
I'm Brittany Butler.
I'm the Executive Director
of the Social Innovation
and Change initiative, which
is a relatively new initiative,
almost two years old,
at the Kennedy School
and an adjunct lecturer there.
I'm representing our
team, the SICI team,
as well as my colleague
Julie Battilana,
who is a professor
at both HBS and HKS.
So I have to say we're
maybe the team that
joined this group the
latest and thus got
to benefit on riding the
coattails of the ethics group,
of the search tool, of the
fact that there will very soon
now be this syllabus
search tool because that's
sort of our next step.
And so thank you, actually,
to HILT for involving us.
So the mission of
the Social Innovation
and Change initiative
the Kennedy School
is to generate new
knowledge, and also
to shape the practice
of innovation
with a social intent.
So not innovation to
make a profit and not
innovation for its
own sake, but to solve
a specific social problem.
And we entered into
this work essentially
because anecdotally,
the student demand
was just like blasting up.
So our team was immediately
overwhelmed by the number
of students coming in and asking
for advice about which courses
they should take, asking about
the I-lab, asking about HIVE,
asking about all the
competitions on campus
and how they should be
navigating those things.
So we entered with a set of
questions about the curriculum,
but also a set of
questions about
extracurricular activities
and how those overlapped.
And the thing about social
innovation, unlike many
of the things that have
been described here--
but I think this is an
increasing trend also
in higher ed-- is it's
not actually a discipline.
At best, it's a phenomena
inside of certain disciplines.
And yet year after year,
the interest from students
keeps rising.
And as we talk to students about
what they want and how they
want to make a difference
in the world, they say look,
there's this specific
social problem I care about.
And what's the
scope and sequence
that I should be
thinking through
as I prepare myself to
go out there and do this?
And so we had terrible
answers for them.
And so like very
basic level, we just
wanted to know what
courses are being taught?
What out-of-class innovation
experiences are offered?
And how do the perceptions
and experiences and demand
from the students
and external actors
about what's available
actually compare to the supply?
I mean, we just didn't
know anything about this.
And so we are very
much in this stage
and looking to go deeper soon.
So again, this is
where we started.
So there was a report done
in 2013 that gave us some
indication that 36% of
cross-registration petition
across all the school--
so this is like a student
making an extra effort
to go into another school
because they perceive
that there's something
at another school that
isn't available in their own--
30% of those fall
into this category.
And many of the students
who made those petitions
were denied.
So we know there's interest.
Just locally, again, the
anecdotes were there.
And then on the supply
side, very spotty.
But the challenge
for us also was
it was difficult
to answer questions
for prospective students.
And at the Kennedy School
and at the business school
in particular, we
were feeling the pain
of actually losing prospective
students because even though we
had this intuition
that as a whole,
Harvard University offers
an incredible amount
on this front, we weren't
able to represent that well,
and that was scaring us.
And then at the same time the
students who were pursuing this
stuff would say, look, I've
already taken--sort of that
first quote that
you started with.
There's a lot of overlap
between these two classes,
and I really wish someone could
have given me a heads up about
that because I don't feel like
I'm optimizing my time here.
That's how we started.
But as we move forward,
some additional questions
surface that,
again, I think, are
important as folks
particularly think
about multi-disciplinary
initiatives, or initiatives
that aren't clearly
in a discipline,
but where student
demand is high,
which is what is Harvard's
responsibility to get clear
about this stuff given
that social innovation,
social change aren't traditional
academic disciplines.
And that's an open
question, but it's something
that increasingly every year
feels like we need an answer.
And what can and
should be accomplished
through the curricular
versus the co-curricular?
So the Social Innovation
and Change initiative
actually runs a
fellowship program.
It's a co-curricular program for
15 select students every year
who are working on advancing
a project that they plan
to continue when they graduate.
They can get up to $30,000
to advance those projects
when they finish.
But is that the only
experience that they should
be getting here in the school?
And how does that
relate to what's
happening in the classroom?
So very much along
the lines of what's
going on with the
research stuff,
and how much is that
shaping students' experience
here is something we want
to understand better.
And then what opportunities
are we missing?
And it just seems like there's
a lot of low hanging fruit
that we don't really
understand yet.
So this is just a
quick sense of how
we approached putting our
arms around this space
and even just defining
what we're talking about.
Lucas, you spent a
lot of time on this.
So just a sample.
This is just a sample.
There are 521 uni courses,
so that's on the next slide.
But this is just a sample.
And look at the range.
Innovators, practice, finding,
building, leading, good ideas.
Applied Music Activism.
Thermal Tectonics for
the Next Billion People.
Designing for the Just City.
Innovative Approaches
to Teacher Prep.
Innovation in Ministry.
These are all processes
that certainly
aren't 100% overlapping,
but where you can really
quickly come to understand
that you need to be
able to define the problem.
There's a set of
competencies here
that each of these
students needs to get.
You need to understand the
root causes of those problems.
You need to be able
to iterate and think
in an iterative learning way
about potential solutions
and make selections
about those solutions.
And you need to understand your
own role as a social change
maker.
And so despite the
fact that they're
all across different
schools and potentially
different in many ways, there's
actually a lot of similarities.
And that's what we wanted
to start to understand.
This is a set of key words.
We followed, again, on the
coattails of the ethics folks
and did this sort
of iterative process
of looking for key words
in the course descriptions.
We would have loved to
been able to drill down
to the level of the
syllabi because we suspect
that when we talk about
the competencies required
to be an effective
social innovator,
it might be happening
at that syllabus level.
And when we get there
we will do that.
But in the meantime,
it just gives you
a sense of the range of search
terms that came up for us,
and then we would feed
those back in to the system
until we came to this 521.
And so yeah, for next year, in
terms of what kind of resources
can we use to support students
and faculty in creating
a community and
finding their way,
we've been thinking about
a compendium of curricula.
We think that just would be an
interesting contribution also
beyond Harvard, and that
that would then draw folks
into the conversation broadly.
Oh, this is our
big takeaway, which
is that pretty much every single
school is offering courses
on this front.
And it's really pretty
well-distributed.
There's an Other group
here that represents
a couple of the schools.
But again, this, just like
Erin said about the other,
this is our first
cut at a snapshot.
We're still trying to figure
out even what the bounds are.
And so a next step for us
will also be connecting with
relevant faculty, faculty who
are interested in this work,
particularly faculty who
have sort of an experiential
learning pedagogy-- they seem
to be very drawn to this--
and ask them for
reactions to the set
of courses we've surfaced.
And then eventually just
make recommendations
to improve the student pathway
for making social impact.
Many of them come here and
say that's kind of why they're
getting an education now.
And so how can we prepare
them to do that well?
And then hopes?
Yeah, just that, again, the
multi-disciplinary learning
journey in particular could be
a little easier for students.
Right now we're very siloed.
I think we all know that.
And they feel it the most.
And then creating a
connection between faculty
and students who would benefit
from working with each other.
Even on this project,
I feel like I've
connected with some
of you who might not
have identified as falling
into social innovation.
But when we get down
to the nitty-gritty,
I think we're actually
grappling with a lot
of similar questions.
And this idea of
developing a one Harvard
ecosystem, especially
when resources
are distributed across schools.
So the Kennedy School cannot
own social innovation,
and we know that.
But Harvard as a
whole really could
be a dominant player in this
space if we could coordinate.
So there are certain topics
where no department, no school
is going to be able to
really shape a field,
but together we might be
able to do quite a bit.
So that's where I'm at.